- When you've had meat in your mouth
the way I have, you just
know what's a good steak.
- I like the taste of steak.
A well-seasoned steak is prime.
- I also don't do raw steak.
I do juicy steak.
- I could eat steak every single day,
even though it's not good for you.
- I get upset when I go to
restaurants and they don't
have A-1 sauce.
What's the point?
- I'm really excited to try these steaks.
- I'm trying to smell to
see if it smells expensive
or cheap.
- This one seems a little bare.
Something I feed my dog or a cat.
- Seasoning's very good though.
Fat's not breaking down, as
well as this when I chewed it.
- It's good when you chew it.
The aftertaste tastes cheap.
- This seems to be a
little bit overcooked,
maybe it's not as high-quality.
- See this looks nice,
it's got a little fat,
but it looks like it
had some marbling in it.
- This one in the middle seems good.
- This, you see this red?
Is a no.
But at the same time,
it's a yes because look
at all that juice.
- This is if a Slim Jim was done right,
like if a Slim Jim was in steak form.
- Tender and it really
breaks down in your mouth
properly when you're chewing it.
It's hard to tell, it really is.
- This one is kind of
like crisp and burnt,
but it's like chewy at the same time,
it still has its flavor and juice.
I'm not mad at this one.
- Taste like $110.
- I'm probably gonna be so wrong.
- This one is super, super tasty.
This one needs A-1
sauce, this one doesn't,
so that means that it's
not the most expensive.
- These two out here seem
to be the best quality.
I could be wrong.
- This one's wet but it's something
that rich people might like.
This might be expensive.
(buzzing sound)
- This is the most expensive steak.
This is the second most expensive,
and this is the least.
- Middle is cheap, this is expensive,
and this is like eh.
- Most expensive, middle ground, cheap.
I'm correct on everything?
I'm gonna reward myself with
some middle-ground steak.
- No!
I knew I would be wrong!
Okay, wait, let me try it again.
- Boom!
All three right.
- This is the reason I
wont' buy a Gucci purse,
cause I'm not there yet, so I enjoy Asos
right here in the middle,
but not Charlotte Russe.
- This one was a little
bit easy to figure out
because you can just tell by the quality.
This just looked overcooked
or just doesn't look
like grade-A meat.
I'd still eat this steak,
and I sure as (bleeped) would eat the hell
out of this steak.
- Drown this in A-1 for this to be good.
So yeah, long story short, I love Asos.
(laughs)